hello we're going to talk about this
subject called ketosis what is it
ketosis is the state of fat burning so
when you're in ketosis you're making
something called ketones
what are ketones ketones are those
things that it's a type of fuel for the
body that's alternative fuel than actual
sugar or glucose so ketones would be
like riding a car using electricity
versus diesel fuel with this which is
more sugar so it's a cleaner fuel source
it's an alternative fuel source that
will give a person way more energy than
glucose so even professional athletes
can far-out run and perform on ketosis
than the carbo-loading ok now how what's
the premise of ketosis the premise of
ketosis is lowering your insulin or your
sugars which is refined carbohydrates
way way way down there too close to zero
like 5 percent of your daily calories
and let me explain what insulin is
though insulin is the hormone that
regulates sugar normally in your blood
you only store in your entire body
two little teaspoons of sugar that's all
you store that's all you have in your
blood so your our bodies were not
designed to consume the amount of sweet
or sugar that week that we consume may
average versus 145 pounds of sugar a
year so that's just insane so anything
more than two teaspoons is going to be
very toxic to the body so on an average
person they're consuming so much
carbohydrate well the body will just
jack up insulin it's like a whiplash
response and then get it out of the
blood fast and stick it into the liver
and start building up fat or on the
liver that's what it does so all these
people with a fatty liver with high
cholesterol high blood fats that is the
sugar in their diet it's not coming from
the fat in the diet our bodies make a
lot of cholesterol 2,000 milligrams a
day so it's not that
in fact here's some interesting things
the good benefits of being in ketosis
which by the way is lowering your carbs
increasing your dietary fats and having
a moderate amount of protein is it will
lower your your bad cholesterol it
increases your good cholesterol it
lowers your triglycerides and improves
blood sugars improve improves in insulin
resistance now there are studies that
will tell you that it worsens if you eat
fat it'll worsen diabetes or insulin
resistance and that has to do with the
type of study that they did it on rats
and they use corn oil they didn't used
healthy fats corn oil is not only
genetic and modified but it's not a
healthy fat so I'm not surprised that
that made things worse so you really
want to when you see these studies that
say that you know something's bad
actually read what they're using as
their fats or their foods and you'll
find that you know even though they just
study on vitamins and they use synthetic
vitamins versus natural so I always kind
of our suspect unless I read this study
myself improve memory improve dementia
good blood sugar levels reducing acne
reducing cancer risk why because sugar
feeds cancer in fact there's even
certain types of scans that they do to
detect cancer and they look for areas of
your body that your Exuma consuming
excess sugar because cancer is very
hungry for sugar so why not just cut the
sugar out and decrease the risk decrease
polycystic ovarian syndrome so what is
that that's a condition where a female
has a lot of these little molecules that
are growing on the ovaries and it's
pumping out too much of the wrong
hormone the male hormone and they're
getting acne lots of hair a lot of
issues but that will do reduce if you're
on this eating plan it decreases
inflammation I mean how many people have
inflammation so sugar will promote
inflammation also digested bloating this
is very good for a digestion
now the healthy fats that you need to be
are basically grass-fed animal products
like beef or something like that do not
consume the lean beefs or the turkey
bacon or the chicken without the skin
why because we need those healthy fats
do not eat eggs without the yolks we
need that fat to be able to get you in
ketosis no but I know the concern the
concern is oh my gosh
I don't want to clog my arteries we've
been literally brainwashed to think that
it's bad for your arteries so all I'm
gonna tell you is try it for a couple
weeks
go get your blood tests and you will see
that it will go down and you'll be I
mean your back cholesterol go down your
heart will be cleaning and you'll you'll
have to prove it to yourself and I'm
gonna I'm gonna list the studies
underneath this video but I want you
personally to experience the benefits of
this because long-term for health
there's running at your body on sugar
you're not going to last and if you
combine sugar with protein you create
even worse problems with insulin and
that's why when I have people that say
well I'm eating mostly healthy
everything in moderation but they have
just enough sugar in there to cause bump
them out of ketosis
so all that saturated fat will plug up
their arteries because they have just
enough to nullify the benefits ok so we
have a lot of benefits we don't want to
combine carbohydrates or too much
protein but I created a link below that
lists the eating plan that I would
recommend types of foods that you should
be on to be able to get yourself into
ketosis
you'll be hearing a lot more of this in
the upcoming news by athletes by
researchers because it is true and it
creates a lot of benefits there's a
couple little twist to it for example if
you've been running your body on sugar
for so long it takes a little bit to
trance adapt your body to this new fuel
source and in that transition you might
have to take it gradual because you're
not used to it
so some people
because the sugar really holds so much
fluid you might drop a lot of water
weight initially and you also might lose
a little too much sodium so you might
need to consume more salt on this diet
to be able to keep the blood the blood
pressure up because it lowers blood
pressure and then you'll feel better but
when you start dumping all this fat and
all this water off your body and you
might feel a little light-headed you
just might need a little bit more salt
so I suggest you push through it it's
only a transition phase but running your
body and ketones it's a much healthier
long term so apply what I just told you
and make some comments underneath this
video